the gyro can experience well when I was
21 and I was first starting to do comedy
that's when I was really devouring as
much of it as possible because I was
trying to figure out like how to not be
so lazy how to be motivated how to get
[ __ ] done and how to how to like find
the correct path and think about things
correctly and so I that's what I'm
really looks like the mind exercise
mm-hmm yeah I would follow all this
personal power like you had workshops
that you would do like a little like
notebooks and [ __ ] and fill out and
things to talk about and things to
concentrate on like if you did do it it
would help you but really what it's all
about it's just getting your [ __ ]
together and moving just go do something
like what you did by taking a job when
you would show up at a gig and you'd be
working there Tuesday through Sunday and
then take a day job and work 9:00 to
5:00 that is more hustle and more hustle
mindset than anything you're ever gonna
get out of an Anthony Robbins book like
that is like just doing it just doing it
makes you do more like do more hardship
makes you do more hard [ __ ] yeah
understand that you want it bad so
you're willing to put into work and do
things you don't want to do it's what
makes you have that confidence that you
know how to push through and that the
mentality that I'm the type of do to get
[ __ ] done like I'm gonna show I'm not
gonna waste my day just sitting around a
[ __ ] hotel room no I'm gonna go to
work I'm gonna work all day I'm gonna
drive five hours and keep that radio gig
and then drive fires and spend ten hours
of the [ __ ] 24 in a day in a goddamn
car for just gigs ford focus just to do
gigs keep that radio gig those things
are every like i had a guy on yesterday
that's got Dan Crenshaw he's a
congressman who's also a Navy SEAL and
we're talking about mentality I'm like
when you went through buds is it do they
teach you how to think or do they show
you by example they don't teach you how
to think they just show you they're
hardened you through all that work and
through all that work to that insane
hell week all the [ __ ] that you have to
do when you're going through buds
training the six months of breaking you
down and building you back up they teach
you could do anything just by making you
do anything
so you will understand how you can pass
your limits what you thought your limits
were are no longer your limits that's
what I feel like is missing from a lot
of people
getting into motivational this
motivational that they ain't doing [ __ ]
you got to go do something that's the
number-one thing right is [ __ ] action
take action do you believe that people
that aren't as successful as you think
they should be or qualified to be
motivational speakers no no that yeah
most people who are doing motivational
speaking should stop they should stop
you're just robbing people
you're not even motivated yourself like
I want to say I want to wake you up at 3
o'clock in the morning go come on man
we're going running like let me see let
me see what you do when you're tired let
me see how you push yourself come on man
get up get up again tomorrow get up
again tomorrow get up again tomorrow the
next day get up get up get up get up
keep going
how long can you maintain a positive
attitude where's all this teaching
you're teaching people you can't do [ __ ]
yourself they need to show people that
you could do it the best motivational
speakers to me are guys like David
Goggins because that that guy that
that's in that [ __ ] that coin right
there that guy does it every day and
he's got videos he just did a 100-mile
race the other day
put up the results on Instagram you can
see him showing up 22 hours after the
race starts he finishes 100 miles like
those type of people
those are motivating Goggins is a
Instagram page but this isn't Centro
he's a [ __ ] animal [ __ ] got
abs on a point he's an animal
he chiseled in he's got the world record
chin ups in in 24 hours he did some
preposterous number of chin-ups what's
that I believe he was beat recently
somebody beat him I think so I want to
have a natural ami yeah okay that's kind
of back back yeah but it's those type of
people those are real motivational
speakers because they're actually doing
something there's a lot of people that
are teaching you motivation they don't
have a business they don't they're not
their business is motivation like it's a
weird business it's like yeah it's like
teaching some how to drive a racecar you
never drove one
[Applause]